Wow
people showed up fast geez I don't think
people would show up this quick oh yeah
okay uh Wow mm-hmm okay how do we turn
on slow mode there we go enable slow
mode okay cool
because I want to be able to see I want
to be able to see you're all questions
there we go can you guys can you guys
hear me at all you guys should be able
to hear me hopefully you guys can hear
me well hey can you guys let me know if
you guys can hear me you guys can hear
me okay cuz there's so many things
coming oh my god okay so Rob cord let me
see some Rob Coors Oh Jason thank you
listen uh let me go to the actual main
we go to the main thing Jason thank you
I saw the super shed I appreciate it for
two bucks yeah let's see some Rob four
types
let's see some people type in Rob cooler
in the chat because I want to I want to
see that pop quiz hotshot who is hold on
okay wait a minute stole okay cool I can
click on it okay pop quiz hotshot is it
Wolverine or Wolverine Wolverine I can't
help but that's just the way this is the
way I say it's the way I've always said
it so I can't I can't help that that
whole thing I've always said it that way
anyway so surprise Q&A session folks
what up like we're doing something we're
doing answer some questions I'm sitting
here I've got a I got a new I got a new
system I'm not gonna show you guys
because my desk is an absolute
Rek I want to show you guys my computer
desk but I'm trying to access my BIOS
and I figured you know what like what
we're doing that like I'll go ahead and
just try to we got a question we got a
question I'm just gonna try to like you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna do a Kuna come
on get into the BIOS BIOS BIOS by us
going know my system boots too fast I've
got a samsung 960 Evo and I've got my
CPU overclock to 4.9 gigahertz and I'm
trying to get to 5 so nerd stuff anyway
uh alright Ghazi Khan Rob question for
you and which commonly does magneto
destroy shields here'll Helicarrier you
mentioned it in a video and now I can't
find it that is in the Jeff Lemire old
man Logan story and I cannot remember
that's the only all different old man
Logan I cannot remember the issue number
it's like it's a flashback um I want to
say it's Bordertown
but I could be wrong like the Bordertown
story arc but I cannot remember off the
top of my head uh wow Joseph Jenkins
thank you for 5 bucks
you are my favorite youtuber I'm the
Rick Sanchez I would try to do it Rick
Sanchez impression but it would be a
terrible it'd be a terrible impression
it would not be very good mr. giggles $2
Wow maybe discord next time I mean I
don't know I mean I use discordant a lot
but I also like live streaming on
YouTube channel from time to time
let's see Jax silver man what are you
gonna do a video on the beyonders versus
the Avengers it's amazing
Rob Corman yes I will do that that's
part of Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers do that stories amazing when
out would Hank Pym when ant-man comes
back and he was just like like I've the
things I've seen I can't unsee like I
watched the beyonders eliminate the
cosmic entities and kill the Living
Tribunal it was it was so oh my god it
was so cool it was so amazing
alright James Allen odds are changing
your fan base to the Jefferson core very
low that that's like 0% the Rob pours
edged in stone let me see some Rob
course shout outs in the chat the Rob
core is etched in stone I cannot I
cannot change that now it's got to be
that way forever forever forever and
ever and ever alright the sole captor
hey Rob would you ever consider
reviewing a
comic I know there are loads out there
that could use a shout out I never
really read write web comics so I
couldn't even begin to tell you which
ones are good and which ones are not I
mean I don't know you know I don't
really read web comics too much so who
would win in a real fight Cable vs
Deadpool probably probably cable but
Deadpool's healing factor might override
the mental control so if it came down to
like just a straight-up fight then
definitely definitely Deadpool most
likely all right Ian Lin sorry guys I
try I try to get to the super chance
first and then jump into everybody else
those comments or everybody else's
questions all right metal best thing
coming out of DC rebirth or best think
of a DC rebirth also is the Batman the
man to a man who laughs out the dope
worst thing ever oh I know he looks
amazing he looks so cool I'm really
excited for Batman the man who laughs um
I think metal is one of the best events
that that's come out of DC rebirth
recently it's it's absolutely stellar in
terms of how it how it unfolds Oh
Richard autumn just ten bucks thank you
I appreciate that um all right do a
wield I just want to say I love your
channel I'm in everyday watcher
I appreciate it I'm glad I mean you know
I thank you guys just just watch my
channel is it's cool enough for me I
mean I'm a big fan ah did you see the
half mention of Conor camp this weekend
Detective Comics I've not read it do not
spoil it dude if you spoil that for me I
swear to god I'll shut the channel down
and I'll never make a video again I
won't actually do that but no I have not
seen that Conor can reveal I know a lot
of people been asking about it and I
know that he had like a little bit of a
reveal in there for those of you guys
who don't know and correct me if I'm
wrong Rob for the Connor can is
basically the Superboy that came after
the death of Superman and then DC never
really knew what to do with him so they
just kept rolling him over and then just
do him on like the Teen Titans oh no he
was on Teen Titans I think he was on
Young Justice um I don't remember anyway
he was thrown onto some teams and then
that was really about it
and um you know he just kind of appeared
here and there but fans loved him fans
absolutely loved it because he got a lot
of character development would you be
kind of interesting um Cody Hobbs thank
you for your for your super chat hold on
for the glory of
think I think I missed that for the
glory I thought somebody said for the
glory of pizza glorious if that's what
you were saying
Donovan Ratliff Rob I really like secret
Empire storylines but it seems like I'm
in the minority here I know you loved it
so why do you think some people hated
the storyline because people got
attached to Captain America the one
thing to keep in mind people read comics
with the real world in mind right like a
lot of people look at comics innocent
escape from the world in a lot of
different ways they just don't want to
deal with everything that's going on at
the moment they just want to look at
things that are happening and they just
want to kind of you know say I'm not you
know interested in that but for a lot of
people Captain America is like the last
vestige of how great superheroes used to
be before all-new all-different marvel
and things changed up to in turn take
that away changes everything because it
would be like making Superman a bad guy
and it would be like making him a
villain in the main DC Universe Captain
America means something to people and so
I understand the argument of people
saying I want him to stay classic
Captain America but I also think it was
time for a change of pace and his
stories and I knew he was anybody who
reads comics for any measure of time
will tell you nothing stays permanent
everything goes back to the way it used
to be if the way it used to be was
popular so it was only a matter of time
before Captain America came back that's
why I just enjoyed the ride I liked it
for what it was so it was amazing
I had one heck of a time but but I
definitely I definitely enjoyed it do
you think legacy will top rebirth I will
grab the Super chats here in a second
guys do you think legacy will top
rebirth definitely I mean I think that
like it I think Marvel is more hungry
than DC rebirth or than DC was I think
Marvel's more desperate than DC was I
think the people a Silver Wing shout out
I think that that that that legacy but
it's too early to tell
to be honest I mean rebirth has planned
out extremely well and so it's it's too
early to know whether or not that's
actually gonna happen okay so into the
Super chats Faust sugar that's I hope I
pronounced that right what are your
thoughts on Dark Knight's metal and DC
bringing back rad man mister miracle
Plastic Man and mr. terrific rad man I'm
not really interested in never really
was too interested in his character I
think there's a very small number of
people who are I think most people don't
know who he is and probably are
concerned I think it can introduce some
cool storytelling and bolster up a
character who's very very obscure mr.
miracle Plastic Man mr. terrific I'm
glad to see them come back
I never got into their stories you know
I never got into that era of DC and so
I'm excited to see those characters
because I'm excited to see what they
bring to the table um yeah we are who do
you think would win Captain Atom
or Superman Captain Atom Captain Atom
easily all right Zack Flores just want
to leave this here won't ask any
questions just hearing that beautiful
voice gets me through the workday I
appreciate it Zack Flores Michael tootle
hey Rob just wondering if the Rob Corps
rings were just for the people who went
to your panel no I'm gonna create some
more and what I'm thinking about doing
is launching like an actual livestream
channel where all I do is this like once
a day I just do livestream q and A's or
every couple a couple days or something
like that and then giving away Rob
coring over there so Wow Michael would
$30 think you just donate in 30 bucks I
appreciate it guys who were not super
chatting I will definitely answer
questions don't worry I do not want you
guys to feel left out
I exist what a great name thank you for
five bucks your videos on world war hulk
got me back into comics thanks would you
ever do a Constantine explained origin
video I would like to um if they ever
bring back the Constantine show
Constantine is just not really popular
enough to worn a video on his own I
definitely do at some point um I mean I
hopefully will that's somewhere along
the line jack silver if you had the
power of reality warping Wow you crann
that in there if you had the power of
reality warping what would be the first
thing you would do would you keep the
power and become omnipotent and live
outside all space and time no I would
basically set it up so that I could
reach into my pocket and have however
much money I needed at any particular
point in time that's what I would do
with reality warping um
Allen Edmonds great Chad wish I could
stay with you but back to work I go yeah
let's go man have a good day
like hopefully you definitely have a
good day alright symbolism thank you for
for five bucks Rob been watching you for
four years I love your content man how
do you think Dark Knight Ximena will
finish and can we see more Dark Side
heroes
I think Dark Knights medal is gonna
finish open-ended I think it's gonna
finish and just say if you want the rest
go read all the Dark Knight and all the
dark you know multiverse comics that are
gonna be coming out I think that's
what's gonna happen with with Dark
Knight's metal um okay so back to the to
the those of you guys who are who are
not doing super chat uh and answering
your questions
all right um when can we play destiny if
you have ps4 add me on on ps4 Marvel
explained I play with fans all the time
but maybe I actually joined the elgible
monster clan um hit up comics Torian and
myself on Twitter and asked us like just
say hey like what's the clan I believe
it's the eligible monster clan for
destiny - and just just hit up requests
to join the clan and we try to grab
people and play on the clan as much as
we can um wonderlad thank you for 5
bucks
would you ever cover the Franken Castle
comics I did not enjoy the comment the
friggin Castle comics they were not
really my my thing I got to get a drink
of water I did not enjoy the freakin
castle comics too much there wasn't
really my wasn't really my thing um okay
uh let's see the New Mutants trailer I
thought it was interesting I'm kind of
on the fence about it
the Nubians thing the movie kind of
looks like a horror thing which I'm not
against I'm actually in favor of the
idea of a horror film involving mutants
just to see where it goes but I don't
know I mean I'm not entirely sure I'm
kind of interested
I mean I'm gonna check it out and I'll
look for more information as it comes
out but for right now I'm just kind of
waiting to see what ends up happening
what is your opinion on okay I miss that
[Laughter]
man I totally missed that have you ever
thought about doing Justice League the
nail that's the story where Superman
died wasn't it like it's a universe
without Superman he died somewhere along
the line I know of it haven't read it um
I would have to read it before I decided
to do it so I have no idea um I have no
no clue show my sexy legs you do not
want to see my sexy legs my legs are not
remotely attractive at all um can you do
more Dragon Ball super videos I've not
been watching Dragon Ball super from
what I understand and let me know like
like I mean it's Dragon Ball super good
right now because I have no idea people
are telling me it's amazing right now
I've been watching geekdom I've been
watching his channel and like it's
insane how well it's doing like it's
it's crazy he's just getting like three
or four hundred thousand views a video
and I was like dude a knee man like you
just is blowing up but like like Dragon
Ball super from what I understand is
it's getting crazy it's getting
absolutely bananas
let's see Solar Fox hey Rob I love your
content can't wait for all right we got
to scroll back up
can't wait for four more you got me into
reading western comics and I thank you
for that do you like the mr. Oz reveal
yes I enjoyed the mr. Oz reveal I think
it's a bruise I think there might be a
little more going on than we actually
are being led to believe but I do like
the idea of mr. Oz I mean with it with
I'm not gonna ruin it for those who
haven't seen it but I mean well
everybody else can hear me right I mean
some people are saying they can't hear
me um I think everybody else if other
people can hear me then it might be the
audio on your end I think everybody else
can hear me fine do a collab with
geekdom I need to do yeah I didn't do
another one he and I need to have a
debate where we debate like Dragon Ball
super versus Dragon Ball Z and which
one's better because I'm gonna Dragon
Ball Z fan I will be until the end of
time Dragon Ball super I couldn't really
get into you because it's not Dragon
Ball Z so but from what I hear it's it's
insane
I know Toriyama is behind the whole
thing so you know I know it's insane I
probably should but uh will you be
willing to do and I'll make it level
Lucifer Morningstar yes you're like the
greatest dude ever bro thanks for
keeping up the great work
I appreciate it yes Lucifer Morningstar
is definitely on the list for Omega
beyond Omega level Omega level things to
be done um let's see have you ever or
will you ever do a comic explain of
Earth X Universe X paradise X by Jim
Kruger yes that's definitely on my
docket no idea when I'll do it but it's
definitely out there to be done so um oh
you hear me in one ear uh all right well
here let me that might actually be I may
not have it set up to go to mono I'm not
gonna do that because I have to restart
the whole thing well let's see stream
yeah I'd have to go back and redo the
whole thing like I'd have to take it
down and then bring it back up and we
would lose like everybody if we did that
Wow Michael would thanks for like 30
bucks BAM dude I love your videos this
is Laurie Laurie fun fun not funky not
I'm not sure I love your videos House of
them is my favorite keep up the great
work
I do love House of M House of M is
pretty insane the way
it all comes together Richard Oldham
would you be willing to oh yeah okay so
you u.s. we already asked to answer that
one for the Omega beyond Omega level um
let's see I did not play World of
Warcraft Jonathan Browning no that was
never my thing uh explanation of Loki or
magic will happen look you will happen
during our videos on Thor that will come
out here in the next month or so yeah I
could change it to mono but I'd have to
take down the whole stream and bring it
back up again so bear with me guys I
apologize it's it's just just a goof on
my part just a mistake on my end so
let's see do another hot wing video well
we're not gonna do another hot wing
video you want to try it with different
foods so we'll probably do like a sour
foods video like where I have to eat a
lemon or something like that and then
explain something along those lines we
want it like we loved the idea of doing
like food challenges like that and
trying to explain stuff so we'll
definitely try try some more of that and
see how it works let's see uh alright uh
Jack Smith your voice is one of the most
pleasing that I've ever heard a long
time on YouTube I often fall asleep to
your videos and then I end up watching
them again to absorb the content I
appreciate that
funny enough I'm dabbling in audiobooks
I'm experimenting with audiobooks and no
idea if I'm gonna actually jump into it
all I'll just be kind of like you know
uploading them to a channel somewhere
that nobody knows about I've posted a
couple of them on Twitter and I'm just
kind of experimenting to see whether or
not it's something that I'm interested
in doing um who would be in your top 10
most powerful Marvel characters ah
molecule man Owen Reese definitely right
now anyway protege the marquee of death
leaving out carriages at the living job
you know we're not gonna get so to them
Franklin Richards probably magneto he's
super powerful Scarlet Witch classic
Doctor Strange I lost count I think
there's two more
Matthew Molloy and then I don't know who
the last one would be maybe Mad Jim
Jasper's be kind of a toss-up uh let's
see
General Rob Ace one of the Rob core here
what's up ace one you think we'll see
some urban Schwab aka ambush bug in the
oz effect or Doomsday Clock
I have no idea who that is I don't know
who ambush bug is the characters that
you guys
no I have no I'd like you guys baffle me
with some of the characters that you
know because I'm just like ambush bug I
mean do I need to read in to ambush bug
I mean is that something that you guys
think would be interesting um let's see
keep crushing it
that's from Tim Michael ah I think it's
how you pronounce it I will keep
crushing it I will continue to crush it
most definitely I will continue to do
that um let's see yeah I know well I
know super is a direct continuation but
I just see I love this cell saga I first
got into super in the middle of the free
I'm sorry I first got into Dragonball Z
in the middle of the frieza saga and
then it was when they were when they
were on Namek and when goku had first
shown up on Namek
that's when I got into Dragonball Z then
I went back and watched the rest well
when they had to rehear I'm back in the
1990s and then Dragon Ball super I know
is a direct continuation so let's see uh
Thanos will win in the infinity war
movie nope I think panels will lose and
I think that nebula will be the one that
takes the gauntlet from him just
finished Hickman's Fantastic Four man
you're right it's so good yes Joe
Caine's it is amazing it is one of the
best stories that you're ever gonna
check out it's to me it's insanely good
it's it's it's pretty stellar the
Hurston Ferrar I love in Colorado and
just just made a video trailer for a
book my friend wrote if you're
interested and reading that link it to
me on Twitter definitely I will check it
out I mean I love reading stuff so if
there's is there like a physical copy of
the book because if there is I'll buy it
and I don't have it I love stuff that
fans do that they link me to you like
I've got a comic book like a fun little
story here
the first major meetup that myself and
comics Torian did was in San Antonio
Texas and this was maybe two years ago
and we met with comicdrake and we hung
out down there for a little while which
I need to go back down to Texas and hang
out with Drake again but we went down to
to San Antonio hung out with him we did
a spur-of-the-moment fan meetup and we
had like maybe 20 of them that's
actually where we first met Dylan from
or over at ORMs comics I think it is but
we ended up hanging out with everybody
and then I had them all signed the cover
of a force from Secret Wars 2015 the
variant covered that had a blank cover
on it with just a force written and it's
one of the most valuable things I have
have it like I have it on display so
it's there's one of my favorite things
that's where I first started forming the
Rob core was meeting up with fans and it
was it was one of the coolest things I
know you were at the reveal at New York
comic-con thoughts on Rorschach no idea
I have no idea how in the head for sure
I came back I'm excited to find out but
I have no idea we don't even know if it
is him like it might just be a low man
masquerading as Rorschach I have
absolutely no idea I'm excited for it
though all right David Bernardi whatever
happened to your opening theme song it
was amazing it ran into copyright issues
I still have to refute those copyright
issues I still get them like somebody
will just like grab the song which I
made the original song the one that I
bought I made it private but people
would just grab it download it put it
put like some crappy rap lyrics to it
and then upload it to like CD Baby or
something like that fun fact I tested
the waters with CD Baby with like tune
core whatever it is they do not ask you
to verify that you actually own the
music all you do is just upload it to
their website and then claim it as yours
so they don't vet any of their guys at
least not as not as I was able to tell
and so suddenly like you to submit a
song and then it's yours and then you
have to go through YouTube to correct it
so there's there's no there's no way to
deal with that like they don't vet
anybody like right now you could go and
grab any song that you wanted to and you
could upload it to TuneCore and then say
it's mine that's my song like that song
belongs to me and then like they have to
verify that it belongs to them so it's
crazy the way it works but let's see if
they'll sugar again another question
would you be willing to do a series that
talks about the obscure weird and
uncanny superheroes and supervillains I
would but I would have to pepper in
heroes that people are interested in the
YouTube game is such that people will
only ever really watch videos about
characters that they know or that are
intriguing if I were to do a video on
like ambush bug I'm not even sure who
that is and the only people who would
watch it are people who are fans of
ambush bug so I'd have to do that video
in a way that it would draw in existing
fans because if the idea is to raise the
profile of characters who are really
obscure it wouldn't make any sense to in
turn talk about that character only to
people who know about that character so
I'd have to find a way to try to beef
that up and make it more popular so
James head Rob core 2 years strong keep
all the good work thanks man like - I'm
so glad ok so I'm curious because like
just
type a number in the chat how many years
have you guys been part of the Rob for
like or just - months like I've been
part of the Rob for for like a month or
like two weeks or just type in the year
- say like two years or something like
that I'm curious how long some of you
guys have been around I think it'd be
kind of cool so alright uh game at a
game a trap
ten bucks thank you for for that ten
dollars I created a destiny comic with
Mahlon games on his Lord Channel I'll be
honored if you could go check out check
it out sometime I drew everything myself
and only got into comics because of your
awesome videos I appreciate that
yeah suits me and send me a link on
Twitter at comics explained to me a link
and and I'll check it out um alright mr.
J hey Rob do you think Black Widow will
die in infinity war and Hulk will turn
into a world breaker Hulk yes I think
that's what's gonna happen like if he's
in love with her I think this was gonna
happen like she's gonna die and he's
gonna freak out and lose his mind and it
would be cool to see him come back and
just just totally lose it or like Betty
Ross will die or something like that
because I think Betty Ross is coming oh
my god okay so Pepper Potts is coming
back dude that's that would be such a
great plot to create like the infinity
war or to create World War Hulk as if
like she dies or Betty Ross dies because
we know that oasiz invading Earth and
dude that would be crazy if like
Infinity Gauntlet turned out to be like
World War Hulk vs. Thanos that would be
insane man Michael wood dude I
appreciate it man oh this is how you ask
questions by the way Dragon Ball super
is amazing do you think the living tiny
the living tiny also will regain his
omnipotence I have no idea I haven't
been keeping track of oh the lobby use
about living tribunal and I also perform
voiceovers at voices.com
and your voice is very pro and here's
some more more Michael Wood I appreciate
it I appreciate that that's awesome
yeah I definitely want to get into
voiceovers I'm actually trying to figure
out a way to do it so oh god people have
been here for years and years and years
um okay uh alright let me click back on
that one uh well Oh Andre Oh Rio Deus I
think it's how you pronounce that I'm
sorry if I screwed that up what do you
think could be done to return to the
x-men mine and yours favorites to their
best can
still be done yes it just takes time I
mean that's all it takes when when DC
killed Barry Allen and crisis on
Infinite Earths in 1985 Barry Allen fans
were pissed
those Barry Allen fans grew to love
Wally West because Wally West had some
great stories now 2011 roll over rolls
around and they end up killing you know
they get rid of Wally West in his
entirety and they only bring back Barry
Allen people you know Wally West fans
were angry so there's always a cycle
things always just rotate it's the
nature of of comedy books it's the way
it always goes you get an agent yeah I
should get an agent create a demo reel
and get an agent I get an agent yes I
think that um definitely Living Tribunal
will get his omnipotence back if that's
who you're referring to
that will definitely happen yeah Pepper
Potts isn't uh not in the comics in the
movies
Gwyneth Paltrow I think is repressing
her role as Pepper Potts an infinity war
let's see Tony Stark as venom or Hank
Pym as Gemini uh Hank Pym is juggernaut
I think it'd be kind of funny just to
see him go through even more of a
personality complex so I think Captain
America will die in infinity war
I think that'll happen I'm not sure but
either that or Infinity Gauntlet
I think you'll end up dying let's see
mr. oz red herring or start to something
deeper I mean if I would like it to be a
red herring that is actually somebody
else but it could be that is a start to
something much larger if it is I mean
I'm excited to see what that larger
thing you know ends up becoming but I
get I did not mean to say get an Asian I
mean to say hidden agent I'm excited to
see what that larger thing ends up being
but but yeah like it'll be it'll be kind
of interesting I'm curious to see so um
man okay uh let's see okay that was okay
um I have you been reading Jessica Jones
I read the first story arc where there
was that guy who remembered the collapse
of the multiverse and then went on a
killing spree because he's like this
universes of mind doesn't nothing I do
here matters anyway that was cool
um but I haven't read any more I know
that there's like the whole thing where
she fights Luke Cage I think but no I
don't know why do people take comics so
seriously because it's something they're
attached to and they love it and they
identify with it and it means something
to them you know it has a far more
deeper meaning than just heroes fighting
heroes and heroes fighting villains it's
an intra it's an intricate part of their
life
so I mean for all you know for all the
comics for all the significance comics
have to that person it'd be like walking
up to you and saying you have to give up
your friend your best friend that's what
it means to people you know right wrong
or otherwise you know it's not a matter
of how it's just how they view comics
and so it's because they're so attached
to them I mean there's nothing wrong
with that that should be celebrated
because it keeps the comic industry
alive so okay guys I only plan on doing
this for about half an hour I didn't
plan on doing it too long I didn't
expect this many people to show up I
expect us to get a thousand people
showing up not at all
so um alright anyway guys I'm gonna
answer one or two more Super chats and
we're gonna bounce off here so what I
think of New Mutants that comes from a
Zygon what's up with New Mutants I enjoy
New Mutants I enjoyed the trailer no
idea what's gonna happen but I thought
the trailer was what's kind of cool um
but alright guys I'm gonna go ahead and
bounce off here thanks for coming out
everybody
it was it's amazing it's cool to hang
out with you guys um like I said I'm
considering starting a channel where I
just do this all the time I think it'd
be kind of a cool thing
but yeah so anyway I'm gonna bounce off
here peeps and yeah I will catch you all
later peace maybe stream how do we okay
here we go